ja eigentlich hätte märz gedacht dass
jemals ein video machen muss
beziehungsweise machen werde weil ich
eigentlich gedacht habe das kommt
niemals so weit aber gut schaut euch an
seit wenn ich böse es ist auf jeden fall
nur eine kurze entscheidung es geht auf
jeden fall bald weiter wie schon gesagt
schaut euch an dann wisst ja meine worms
geld viel spaß
hey leute was klappt willkommen beim ein
video ja heute in diesem video wollte
ich euch ganz kurz erklären bzw
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
ausführlicher warum von mir oder was
gerade so erst mal bei mir los ist und
warum in den nächsten zwei wochen
vielleicht nicht ganz so viel auf
youtube kommen wird bzw
er gar nicht das geht euch natürlich
alles was an deswegen wollen wir auch
gar nicht lange lagern wir fangen sofort
man doki bevor wir jetzt irgendwas
negatives sagen ich muss erstmal sagen
wir haben wirklich in den letzten 365
tagen bzw
im letzten jahr haben wir krass viel
erreicht so wenn ich mich daran zurück
erinnere wo ich so jetzt vor einem jahr
war ich meine wir sind auf youtube fast
400.000 auf instagram keine ahnung wie
viele auf snapshot keine ahnung wie
viele das sind alles zahlen wie für mich
voll krass sind und dann die ich vorher
nie denken konnte es ist alles voll
unrealistisch wenn man sieht ja oder ein
video macht so und so viele klicks und
so also wirklich voll krass danke darf
ich bin mega stolz darauf um ehrlich zu
sein dass ich das geschafft habe jetzt
damit einfach so viele menschen zu
erreichen
aber das ist auch eine sache also diese
ganzen klicks voller war aufmerksamkeit
sind natürlich auf der einen seite
richtig positiv auf der anderen seite
aber auch für mich gerade wie soll ich
sagen die ziele auf so eine negative
sache mit sich falls man es so sagen
können und zwar wie ich das ja auch
schon ziemlich oft gesagt habe youtube
videos habe ich damals angefangen weil
ich bock drauf hatte viel spaß daran
gehabt habe meine community aufzubauen
und ich bin wirklich jeden morgen
aufgestanden und habe mir gedacht war
heute bist du wieder motiviert irgendwas
geiles zu drehen und du machst halt
irgendwas letztes hoch ich hatte beim
schneiden total bock gehabt drei videos
die woche gemacht weil ich wirklich
richtig krass bock drauf hatte ja und
irgendwann kann man hat wirklich immer
mehr menschen dazu pro tag haben 1000
2000 manchmal auch 6000 menschen am tag
kam dazu was für mich heftig war und das
hat mich natürlich immer weiter
motiviert ja da muss dranbleiben muss
weitermachen und ich habe auch wirklich
spaß dann also wie schon eben gesagt ich
bin morgens aufgestanden wollte wieder
irgendwas cooles drehen für euch was
geschätzt wird was geiles feedback
bekommen so was halt wirklich immer und
ich hatte wirklich krass spaß dran
und ja dann kann man diese ganzen
menschen dazu menschen dazu menschen
dazu und das ist ganz normal das ist
wirklich ganz normal das hat jeder
youtuber meines erachtens es ist schwer
irgendwann
wie soll ich sagen ich sag mal so es ist
wirklich schwer sich die ganze zeit
nicht auf diese zahlen zu konzentrieren
sondern einfach nur das zu machen was
einem spaß macht und das ist bei mir in
letzter zeit dass das kommt immer weiter
mehr hoch dass ich auf die zahlen achte
dass ich oft tokio geliebt diesen monat
im vergleich zu diesem monat alles lief
schlechter scheiße und so weiter und man
vergisst aber einen spaß und das ist
wirklich schlecht so das ist ja schlecht
habe ich das jetzt gesagt wie sehr genau
ok also erstmal was heißt man vergisst
dabei einen spaß also der spaß bleibt
auch da aber marco klein auch auf diese
zahlen so dann hab ich jetzt meinen
schulabschluss gemacht ich habe mein
abitur gemacht und hab mir gedacht so
nah kommen was machst du fängst an zu
studieren oder vielleicht noch nicht und
ohne scheiß alle leute dich gefragt
haben ja was meint ihr soll ich jetzt
studieren oder soll ich vielleicht was
anderes machen die er mir gesagt hey du
kannst du auch anfang nächstes jahres
anfangen zu studieren und jetzt einfach
mal youtube machen ich meinen bei
deloitte zucker heftig warum mache ich
einfach youtube macht das was worauf er
bock hast coopers darum kommt wie viel
du erreichen kannst
und dann hab ich wirklich immer mehr
gedacht oder immer mehr gemerkt haben
recht macht doch einfach das was dir
bock macht und fange nächstes jahr nicht
mein ein halbes jahr pause fatih akin
man kann ja einmal so das machen was
einem spaß macht ich mein ich bin jetzt
zwölf jahre jeden tag zur schule
gegangen das war dann wirklich auf
seinen punkt der so hinzu kamen wo ich
mir gedacht habe york kommen du
konzentrierst dich jetzt ein halbes jahr
nur darauf und ziehst krass durch dass
du alles damit zerstörst und so weiter
auf ihren zweiten video beziehungsweise
fünf videos die woche gibt sein bestes
snapshot instagram blablabla was noch
alles gibt musicali falls ihr das kennen
und ich kann für mich sagen was ich an
mir persönlich auch sehr mag ich habe
den ehrgeiz dass ich das wirklich
durchziehen würde bzw
auch durchziehen kann nur die sache ist
man sollte bei dem ganzen nicht
vergessen dass man einmal angefangen hat
weil es ihm spaß gemacht hat und ich bin
halt wirklich gerade auch so einen weg
wo ich merke dass wenn ich wirklich jede
woche da so viel rein investiere und
auch videos machen die mir vielleicht
nicht so spaß bereiten dass der spaß
dabei immer weiter runter geht sage ich
mal ja und ich war dann jetzt auch noch
eine woche im urlaub vor zwei wochen
oder so und habe auch wirklich im urlaub
jeden tag an youtube gearbeitet obwohl
es ja eigentlich urlaub ist so ich
wollte den urlaub dazu nutzen noch
weiter voran zu kommen
dann bin ich nach hause gekommen habe
hier weiter gemacht und jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch einen letzten
videos gemerkt letzte woche die sind
halt alle online gekommen so die sind
auch nicht so gut angekommen platt
ferien es sind nicht so viele leute auf
youtube wie sonst aber man hat doch
wirklich gemerkt so ich bin nicht mehr
so wie vor zwei wochen oder drei wochen
weil ich halt wirklich überhaupt keinen
spaß an diesen videos entwickeln konnte
klar ich werde nicht sagen dass mir
überhaupt keinen spaß gemacht hat
youtube videos ich mein youtube ist
meine hauptplattform das macht mir immer
noch ein bisschen spaß aber halt nicht
mehr so viel spaß wie vor zwei wochen
noch falls ihr das versteht weil ich
halt wirklich jetzt vor allem in dieser
zeit wo ich nur youtube mache mich krass
darauf konzentriere und durchziehen will
und dann als vielleicht zu viel mache wo
ich gerade mercurio die letzten drei
videos das bist einfach nicht so
wirklich du bzw
du bist nicht so cool wie du mal davor
warst weil man halt den spaß nicht in
den videos mehr das haben gar nicht so
viele geschrieben aber ich hab's mich
selber gemerkt und wenn ich was für mich
selber merke ist das nur der punkt wo
ich sagen muss ja komm du musst jetzt
mal aufpassen und sollte es vielleicht
nicht zu viel rein stellen bzw
dich zu viel darum kümmern sondern
einfach mal dein leben leben und youtube
ein bisschen außen vor lassen vor allem
es rechtlich im urlaub youtube zu machen
ich meine ich bin im urlaub da kann man
sich doch entspannen und muss ich den
ganzen tag auf youtube hängen
beziehungsweise jeden tag gucken wie sie
stars wie sie stars ist nicht wirklich
wenn ich so zurückblicke auf die letzten
monate 6 millionen klicks 5 millionen
klicks ist ultra krank für mich und das
ist vielleicht auch so ein
ausschlaggebender punkt warum ich jetzt
sage ja du musst jetzt mal an dich
denken und vielleicht nicht an youtube
und danke dass du wusstest das einzige
was jetzt damit sagen will ist dass ich
lehrer muss mich wieder auf mich selber
zu konzentrieren und youtube vielleicht
ein bisschen sacken lassen muss ja zu
merken dass es noch ganz viele andere
tolle leben im tolle leben im pass gibt
tolle dinge im leben gibt völlig sagen
genau
und ja ich muss halt wer den spaß wieder
dran zu finden
ich bin mir auch sicher dass ich den
sport wieder dran finde wenn ich halt
weniger mache und wieder das finden was
mir bock hab ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
hab grad in letzter zeit nicht so viele
krasse videos gemacht weil ich einfach
nicht kreativ bin ich bin nicht gerade
in der lage was was cooles für euch zu
entwickeln weil ich jetzt wirklich so in
den letzten zwei wochen krass viel daran
gearbeitet hat und so weiter es war auch
so viel drum rum da davon wisst ihr
alles nichts aber ich muss jetzt
wirklich checken jo du willst es einfach
mal und kommt irgendwann so ein
wieder in diese kreative phase und dann
geht's ganz normal weiter also für mich
persönlich sieht das eigentlich so aus
was die zukunft angeht diese woche mache
ich es einfach mal gar nichts ich habe
auch ferien ich kann doch auch einfach
mal an mich denken wie schon gesagt
nächste woche bin ich noch eine woche im
urlaub und dann bin ich mir auch sicher
habe ich wieder richtig bock auf youtube
und nicht so wie ja man steht halt jetzt
stehe ich morgens auf und denke mir acom
du musst ja irgendwas machen damit
youtube oder was auf youtube gut ankommt
ja und das war vor zwei wochen halt
anders und in diesen zwei wochen habe
ich gecheckt jetzt ist stock jetzt lässt
du das kurz für zwei wochen
ich bin zwei wochen auf jeden fall
wieder zurück am start weil ich bin mir
zu 100 prozent sicher dass er wieder
richtig coole videos auf euch zukommen
deswegen ihr müsst jetzt nicht denke ich
so oder so das werde ich niemals machen
youtube ist richtig wichtig ein
richtiger teil meines lebens schon seit
einem jahr oder so jetzt wirklich
deswegen das würde ich niemals an ist
wie so ein kleines baby zeigt man ja
immer heisst es weiter vergesst nicht
ich bin und zwei wochen wieder zurück
und dann kam richtig gute sachen habe
ich so ich hoffe ihr versteht das alles
und könnte das gut nachvollziehen das
ist halt manchmal so ist ich bin da ganz
offen und ehrlich es gibt auch sehr
viele die das einfach unterdrücken man
merkt an in den videos wird sagen ich
wünsche euch eine tolle ferien falter
ferien habt wir sehen uns dann in zwei
wochen auch einen schönen urlaub falls
hat im urlaub sei als achso und
vielleicht in zwei wochen bin ich jetzt
auf youtube nicht aktiv instagram und
musical i hab ich jetzt mit angefangen
also mit diesem musical mache ich ein
paar musicals mit meiner freundin hat
zumal da könnt ihr uns folgen also
kleine eigenwerbung noch am schluss
damit ihr mich nicht zwei wochen gar
nicht sehen ob instagram heißt ich alex
wieder erfolge mir wahrscheinlich auch
viele schauen und ob musical heißt real
alexy vielleicht endlich den namen auch
wenn ich dazu führen bei einer freundin
mache kann ich ja nicht nur alex auf
jeden fall ist das alles und in der
video beschreibung verlinkt ich wünsche
euch wie gesagt eine schöne zeit in
diesen zwei wochen wir sehen uns in zwei
wochen auf youtube wieder falls die
rosserer oder musical und dieses video
hat mir jetzt gerade sogar wieder spaß
gemacht weil es einfach realtech ist und
ja es muss halt sein und das war es
manchmal nicht in den letzten videos
deswegen ich hoffe ihr versteht das ihr
seid cool sich auch ein bisschen und ich
fand jetzt einfach mal schluss machen